bonsoir à tous d'abord je vous rassure
je suis trop vieux pour être sergents
recruteurs
donc le but c'est pas du tout de vous
dire engagez vous rengagez vous c'est
simplement avec le recul dû à mon grand
âge et puis avec quelques années a
modestement à parcourir la planète vous
dire un petit peu ce que je comprends
quand j'entends s'engager il ya plein de
façons de le faire intelligemment il ya
plein de façons de s'engager pour des
causes qui nous dépasse vous le savez
bien j'espère que vous avez trouvé la
vôtre que ce soit pour le faire
temporairement accorder du temps faire
partager vos talents soi même en avoir
fait votre profession ou encore un
engagement un engagement pour la vie
bien entendu s'engager quand on cherche
la définition de ce mot sur le
dictionnaire on trouve tout un tas de
deux définitions possibles pour moi
s'engager se traduit par deux verbes en
fait qui sont importants pour pour le
soldat que je suis le premier c'est
promettre et le second c'est combattre
là encore promettre et combattre peuvent
prendre beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
formes
je vais commencer par promettre
promettre d'abord il ya évidemment le
corollaire qui est être fidèles
respecter respecter sa parole respecter
sa signature
ce sont des sujets qui sont extrêmement
importants pour les soldats parce que
notre système est un système de
contractuels dans l'armée de terre 70 %
des soldats quel que soit le grab sont
des contractuels
quand jeudi des soldats officiers
sous-officiers ou militaires du rang par
ailleurs nous en recrutons y compris en
période de déflation quinze mille par an
donc il est extrêmement important pour
nous de quelque part sacraliser le
contrat alors c'est important parce que
évidemment la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui qui
est bien meilleure que celle que je
représentais à mon époque a quand même
des caractéristiques un peu différente
globalement de zappeurs hédoniste
voilà or notre métier est un métier
compliqué quand même est un métier
faire le premier pas pour venir doit
coûter oui nous sommes engagés dans une
concurrence importante pour recruter
parce que parce que là ma foi tout ça se
fait c'est des jeux à somme nulle avec
beaucoup d'autres métiers
mais en même temps nous devons faire
comprendre que venir chez nous ça n'est
pas simple ça n'est pas simple venir
chez nous ça n'est pas simple et puis en
plus nous après derrière il faut
confient les lisent il faut garder parce
que notre système
notre système et rage pour parler
technique repose sur des flux de
promotion interne 50% des officiers son
ancien sous-officier et 70% de
sous-officiers sont d'anciens militaires
du rang j'étais la semaine dernière à la
cérémonie de départ d'un de mes vieux
camarade officier général qui a commandé
qui a commencé sa carrière comme jeunes
militaires du rang ici à lyon
donc c'est très important de de
sacraliser ça de faire comprendre que on
ne s'engage pas sur un coup de tête
on vient si on veut et on reste si on
veut oui on vient si on veut on reste si
on veut bien sûr mais l'individu ne peut
pas faire ne peuvent pas pénaliser le
collectif alors c'est quoi les recettes
il y en a pas il y en a pas surtout que
juridiquement tout ce que je dis repose
sur rien mais c'est convaincre un jeune
garçon ou une jeune fille de venir chez
nous est de rester chez nous parce que
il a besoin de nous mais aussi et
surtout parce qu'on a besoin de lui
voilà c'est tout le sujet sur lequel je
ne m'étendrai pas considérant le temps
qui m'est imparti de la place de
l'individu dans le collectif et est chez
nous comme beaucoup comme dans une
entreprise
j'ai changé hier avec un avec un chef
d'une grande entreprise lyonnaise
il s'est lui aussi c'est pareil en plus
en ça ne peut pas faire deux parce que
si ça ne fait que deux à ce moment là
c'est que la boîte ne fonctionne pas la
performance pour parler riche
la performance n'est pas là un plus un
ça doit faire beaucoup plus que deux et
pour ça il faut que la somme que léa
individuel se sentent bien là où ils
sont de façon à ce que c'était la chimie
humaine fonctionne donc
c'est s'engager c'est promettre c'est
promettre et s'y tenir
ça c'est quelque part quand même sens
assez commun même si je vous ai dit que
ça résonnait beaucoup chez nous mais
s'engager c'est aussi combattre
combattre il ya là encore plein de
façons de combattre et j'essaierai de
vous illustrer sa avec 2 2 3 2 3 photos
d'expérience mais ce qu'il faut
comprendre d'abord ces deux choses c'est
que combattre c'est d'abord avoir
compris que chacun ait compris le plus
jeune a un potentiel de catastrophe
phénoménal dans les mains qui s'appelle
une arme de guerre ça n'est pas que un
problème de chaîne c'est un problème
surtout deux plus jeunes
la victoire allait collective le succès
il est collectif mais le plus jeune peut
faire tout capoter
donc il faut que la compréhension de
l'action soit partagé par tous y compris
les plus jeunes
or les plus jeunes c'est qui je le dis
avec affection c'est ce sont des jeunes
niveau 3e qui parlent le français comme
ça qu'ils l'écrivent comme il le parle
bon voilà mais mais mais ça va ça nous
suffit
mais il faut quand même s'attacher à
leur faire comprendre tout ça le
potentiel de catastrophe
il est décentralisée jusqu'au plus petit
niveau
alors évidemment tout ça l'engagement il
est il est dans nos métiers comme dans
d'autres je suppose il est total il est
physique il est intellectuel il est
moral il est moral alors un soldat
j'aime pas le mode militaire le mode
militaire est un mot fade c'est un
statut cessé de la ra assez le vrai mot
ses soldats et puis et puis pourquoi
aurait-on peur des mots le vrai mot ces
guerriers voilà donc des soldats prêts
physiquement parce qu'ils sont au
contact de la géographie physique
les soldats savent que quand il pleut ça
mouille les pieds quand il fait froid il
n'y a pas là il n'y a pas de chauffage
quand il fait chaud il ya pas la clim
voilà et donc il faut savoir encaisser
ça c'est ces soldats ils doivent être
mentalement prêt mentalement prêt c'est
d'avoir pris conscience de leur
importance dans le collectif
c'est ça fait mentalement prêt le
courage le courage il se décrète pas
personne ne connaît ses limites
avant d avoir atteint personne ne sait
voilà la seule chose qu'on peut dire
avec un peu de recul
c'est que c'est pas forcément le fort en
gueule qui est le plus courageuse saluée
même rarement la compétence la
compétence elle l'est elle n'est jamais
acquise advitam elle est remise en cause
en permanence en permanence en
permanence en permanence formation
continue il n'ya on ne perd aucune
occasion pour répéter répéter répéter et
ont dit aux chefs commandés s'est répété
le professionnel n'est pas celui qui
réussit une fois des choses extrêmement
compliqué et c'est seul loïc qui réussit
tout le temps quelles qu'en soient les
circonstances des choses simples mais
combattre ça n'est pas que l'action du
guerrier qui vise à neutraliser
l'adversaire c'est même c'est même
totalement insuffisant et ce depuis
longtemps il faut que l'action du
guerrier du combattant soit légitime
légitime aux yeux de qui d'abord à ses
yeux lui-même il faut lui expliquer aux
yeux de sa famille aux yeux de notre
opinion publique aux yeux de la
population auprès de laquelle on
intervient il faut donc notre pour faire
un peu courts sont jouer sur les mots
notre mission est depuis très longtemps
c'est plus vaincre c'est plus seul
vaincre c'est surtout qu'on veut c'est
surtout convaincre et un chef en
opération n'est pas simplement un chef
de guerre
c'est un développeur c'est aussi un
homme qui parle de roul vélo c'est là
aussi un homme qui parle de gouvernance
ces photos là c'est l'afghanistan 2010
il s'agissait de quoi de convaincre une
population qu'elles avaient de meilleur
un meilleur avenir avec ces autorités
locales plutôt qu'avec des taliban le
plus souvent étrangers qui aura posé une
façon de vivre qui n'était pas la leur
convaincre c'est pas leur style
donc c'est dans la durée tout le temps
deux jours de nuit à pied discuter et
c'est dangereux parce que parce que à
pied c'est pas un wargame sepa sepa sepa
dans un blindé s'est pas c'est au
contact c'est au comptant
et le travail d'un chef c'est de ne
risquer la vie de ses hommes et tiennent
évidemment qu'après être sûr d'avoir
travailler travailler travailler
travailler et encore travailler toujours
pour être sûr d'avoir réduit au maximum
les risques inhérents à un engagement
militaire
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
conclusion j'ai parlé de l'engagement du
soldat mais nous ne sommes rien d'autre
que ce que nos familles nous autorise à
être quand on s'engage physiquement
intellectuellement moralement de façon
aussi lourde
a manca blement il y a aussi le sujet
des familles qui est derrière et ce sont
des affaires que l'on prend extrêmement
au sérieux
un soldat s'engage mais c'est pas lui
qui s'engage c'est tout un ensemble qui
sans gâcher tout son entourage qui
s'engagent à commencer par une famille
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire dans
le temps qui m'était imparti et je vous
souhaite